المساعدات الدوليه تتهافت على تركيا بعد
الزلزال وتبقى محدوده على سوريا
قال البنك الدولي انه بصدد تقديم مساعدات
الى تركيا بقيمه مليار وسبعمائه
لتمويل اعمال الاغاثه والتعافي في اعقاب
الزلزال المدمر
سنقدم مساعده فوريه ونعد لتقييم سريع
للاحتياجات الميدانيه العاجله والعائله
المساعده ستستخدم لاعاده اعمار البنى
التحتيه الاساسيه بعد هذه الكارثه هذا ما
صرحه رئيس البنك الدولي
منظمه الصحه العالميه عبرت عن خشيتها من
حدوث ازمه انسانيه كبرى من شانها التسبب
باضرار تضاف الى ما خلفه الزلزال
انا في طريق الى سوريا حيث سنقدم الخدمات
الطبيه الاساسيه للسكان في المناطق
المتضرره من الزلزال الاخير هذا ما غرده
المدير العام لمنظمه الصحه العالميه
على تويتر
وكان الاتحاد الاوروبي قد ارسل طليعه
المساعدات الى تركيا بعد ساعات من الزلزال
لكنه لم يقدم سوى مساعده محدوده الى سوريا
بسبب العقوبات الدوليه
المفروضه عليها